you said this in general this is also
one of the reasons men find youth
attractive you want to blow up the
internet or block the internet write
effing now the reason 18 and 19 year
olds are more attractive than 25 year
olds is because they've been through
less dick people say oh you can't say
that but yes I can a 19 year old is more
attractive than 26 year old woman and
I'll tell you why because that 26 year
old has talked to more guys been to the
club more times being effed and dumped
more times more arguments More Mess more
for me to clean up that is misogyny why
because you are encouraging a mindset
about 25 year old women that makes them
sound out to be
infinitely less desirable than 18 19
year olds and having effectively been
having too much sex to be taken in a
more respectful way that would well
firstly even if that was the case they
wouldn't be misogyny but what did you
mean by what you said that's not
misogyny because it's not anti-women I'm
saying that an 18 or a 19 year old woman
would be more pretty anti-25 year old
woman anti-25 year old woman we can
argue